[Music]
all right welcome to here at the st.
lous chess club and today my team will
talk about is how people are not pawns
and it sounds funny it is kind of funny
but there's some deeper chest truths to
it and so I'm gonna try to get into that
today the game we're looking at today
it's Smith Slough against Walter brown
America's one and only from 1970 and
I'll maybe even talk a little bit about
this tournament that they're playing in
as we get into it now
this is an in-game lecture so I'm just
going to cruise through the opening
moves here
and this is a system that Smith Slough
used against Kings Indian setups often
and it looks pretty tame but actually
there's a bit of venom in it and so
blackened dude many different things he
plays brown plays d6 this is probably
still find and we get this position here
where I still think well it's let's call
it theory or whatever you want to say
black that black hasn't made any
controversial moves so 93 and then
Browns first really strange move in the
game which honestly I've spent a lot of
time trying to figure out like why he
did it like I spend a lot of energy
trying to figure out why Brown made this
ugly-looking move he played Queen c8 and
it's really an abysmal move I guess I
guess stressing the guest part that his
intention is to trade off the bishop on
g2 here however you know even if he were
to achieve this it's not that easy for
example so for example even if me Slough
it played efore Bishop h3 let's say rook
e1 we still have a beautiful
noxee bind position for white any case I
assume that was his intention and before
I leave this I just want to make a quick
note I promised myself I wasn't going to
do this but I got it because it's just
such an interesting thing but plan that
black can play in these positions
whether white plays b3 or Bishop g2 well
well let's use it with the b3 b3 knight
c6 Bishop b2 Bishop g7 and now if you
want to do this weird queen c8 idea this
is a tangent by the way I just want to
meet I just want to point out well maybe
it's not so much of tennis let's just
talk about this for a second so this can
go like this could have castle first
it's gonna be the same deal in a
position like this what's very
interesting is that now Queen c8 is not
so dumb and this is actually there's so
many ways you can talk about how pawns
aren't people but the let's get into it
right okay so the first way in which
most people understand that pawns aren't
people is that you should be willing to
sacrifice them to get your pieces moving
and so that's just a fundamental
block that every chess player has to get
around a psychological block and that's
very important and that's definitely
part of the message of pawns aren't
people but what I'm talking about here
is this other deeper thing where all of
us have certain notions about what you
do in certain pawn structures and I
think it's very debilitating this notion
of pawn structures being equated with
plans and I think my chess was largely
ruined when I was a kid because I
I went into the local library back then
there were these things called books
that you would read about chess and one
for example was I remember
Hans cokes book about pawn structures
and just pages and pages and it felt
like very deep and philosophical so my
young mind was very drawn to this thing
but it was all about you know what you
do in certain pawn structures you know
what what you're fighting for in Yatta
Yatta and let me just use this position
as an example in the other position
queen c8 didn't make much sense but now
queen c8 has a lot more bite and there's
a very key difference that has not
anything to do with pawn structure and
everything just to do with piece
placement and that is that now black has
the option of playing age five age four
and it looks barbaric this thing but
there's two things to notice one the
rook is on h8 and two is also very
important
the King is actually defending this e
seven square which would be the natural
way for white to create some drama with
Knight c3 d5
because the standard saying goes that
when and then attack on the wing is met
by an attack in the center but here the
King is remarkably stable even though it
doesn't look right okay so what do I
want to say with this example it's not
the pawn structure
it's the pieces forget the pawns the
pawns are a the setting of what's going
on and they should be sacrificed for the
active activity of the pieces and I
don't just mean sacrifice in the sense
of giving them away but I need sacrifice
in the sense of maybe creating a
weakness right having some struggle with
the pawns okay let's go back to the game
in this position Queen c8 makes no sense
to me anyways like I said I fought long
and hard trying to understand all right
rook c1 and now black gives up on the
plan of Knight takes d4 and I assume
that the reason was something he was
worried about bishop
three Knight d5 so we're threatening
knight c6 97 like I said the e 7 point
comes under fire and of course if Knight
d5 CD is a disaster
but even here he could have I guess
played this position with this miracle
move and we get this mess where white is
definitely better but black could
conceivably play this position
all right so rook c1 Knight takes d4
Queen takes d4 Bishop c6 all right
here's the first big moment for thinking
about the presuppositions of both
players here now let's say some obvious
things white is ahead and development
and white has more space and this second
thing of having more space is what's
going to encourage black to play Bishop
c6 to try to trade some stuff off now in
this regard we can say firmly that Queen
c8 was a full loss of a tempo
okay now that isn't necessarily mean
he's lost but it means that he's gonna
suffer
I think the idea of rook c1 shut down
the idea of his idea of Bishop h3 but
note that black structure is still
fundamentally sound we could call this a
dragon structure right and we're going
to talk a little bit more about this
dragon structure but this is a real
interesting position for us to think
about here
I think that what I would certainly do
here and I think most players would do
and let let me show is 95 with red knee
night take c7 and the variation could go
something like this
Bishop takes and C takes as possible but
I like this better because I like that
beautiful bishop and of course you can't
take the bishop because this is mate
over here on g7 so Knight h5 we can get
a variation like this and the the thing
that's very interesting about this
position and is going to be a factor for
us in this game is that smyslov
is of a much older chess school that we
are now today today after Fischer
shortly after this kind of proves the
idea of the fischer end game which is
rook and Bishop destroys rook and Knight
and that that's definitely something we
can talk about in a different endgame
lecture but in that in that demolition
especially with the Timon off match
people then started to say oh the bishop
is stronger than the Knight and I would
definitely save the bishop stronger than
a knight in this position Smith law
however is of this older school which
really wants to say that the knight and
the bishop are really fundamentally
equal now that doesn't mean that there
are some positions that the bishops
thrives in in some positions that the
knight thrives in but fundamentally
they're equal beasts they just do
different things
so one of the interesting things about
this position and imagining Smith Slough
maybe going into it is that for him the
advantage wouldn't be as apparent as I
think most GM's now would say white is
clearly better in this position okay and
to understand that that prejudice is
important because it helps us understand
this move which takes I think a lot of
tactical ingenuity just to think of it
and basically Smith Slough is gonna play
to kill this bishop and he plays d4 now
the reason that this move this is really
a star move I don't even know if it's
better than ninety five but it's a star
move just because it shows tactical
creativity most people even think about
it because you're worried about a Knight
takes e4 and it's like oh yeah I just
blundered something serious and so what
did he see he saw this trick Knight d5
check and then wherever you go
this thing's gonna go with check and so
we'll take this thing and we'll have the
two bishops plus a weak pawn with a
clear advantage so what's interesting
about this efore move is not only is it
a good move but it's gonna set the stage
for what smyslov
thinks the pawn structure battle now
should be and in terms of pieces what
he's saying is he wants to work against
this piece he's going to try to make
this piece poor and it's for the most
part a great strategy but we're gonna
see he's so committed to it that it's
going to be he's going to miss some key
opportunities and we're gonna see black
has some pawn structure ideas as well
that's gonna make him miss some basic
opportunities and so I'm gonna say this
maybe twice just because it's such a
interesting thing but I'm gonna put in
personal context
you know I one of the things about just
the way I don't know my chest is or what
I believe in chess is that I really
believe in going over your own games and
one very interesting thing for me is
just recently I was analyzing a game
that I lost and in analyzing it I found
I had a lot of presuppositions about the
pawn structure now so it's a funny thing
you can shout in a philosophical manner
as I'm now doing in this lecture that
you should believe that pawns aren't
people and that you should not allow the
preconceptions of the pawn structure to
guide you but it's funny as it may be
it's especially for a guy like me grew
up in an older generation who read that
comic book and there was this Andy
Soltis books I think was called pawn
power and chess or something like that
and they ruin you because they they
disturb your sense of what the pieces
are about and the pieces are more
important
all right so II for huge ingenuity just
to shut that Bishop on c6 down Queen d7
now this is part of a plan that Brown
has to play Queen d7 but I'm gonna say
it even though it doesn't change the
nature of the position too much what I
don't like about it is that it removes
the possibility of 97 and so one of the
key things about a space advantage in
general is like here you will often have
squares that more than one of your
pieces wants to move through right like
here the queen is in the way of the
night
hence trading some stuff is in blacks
interest notice also that it is true
what this means left is working with
he's jamming this bishop right he's
saying
it can do absolutely nothing and it's
kind of in the way of all the black
pieces and that's fundamental to see
both the good parts of it's coming moves
in a couple of his mistakes
so Queen d2 rook fc8 rook fe1 and now a
six this is all pretty standard stuff
especially from a guy like brown who
plays the Sicilian and he's going to
dream of a b5 break and although I don't
think a6 necessarily ruins it for him
after a four things are pretty difficult
because it is very difficult to actually
ever play b5 in a meaningful way so I
think for example b5 I think I take it
and you can't do that because of a 5 and
if you go back I think there's this
trick here a 5 and then I'm winning a
piece so this is gonna be a little bit
of a problem long term where black is
going to shut the Queen side down rook a
b8 and now here's our first interesting
moment that I want to share with you I
hope it's not the first exit but it is
one of the interesting moments about the
question the first let's go that's the
first interesting moment with a question
of Knight d5 ok so
what I think what's going on here is
Smith Slough does not want to play
Knight d5 for a couple reasons the first
and most important is he doesn't want to
trade the bishop on c6 and we're gonna
look at a couple of these but the 95
honestly it seems to me to really always
lead to a very pleasant position for
example Bishop takes pawn takes were
freeing the e rook and b5 to doesn't
work at all because of something like
this and notice I'm gonna hammer the
rook down on c6 very soon
I think this position is actually lost
and if instead you don't play b5 and do
something like this I'm probably going
to just gang up on the e pawn and again
have a very centralized and beautiful
position now that said I don't think
Knight a 2 which was played in the game
is a mistake again
Smith laughs is gonna use tactics to
make b5 uncomfortable maybe I'll show
that first b5 Knight d4 C B and a5 was
also good but this is nice because we
are going to on this move we can take
and play e5 and it's again it's a wreck
so that's not possible and what we're
doing is a very small improvement of the
position now in last week's lecture I
talked about the difference between
arsonists and builders arsonists being
players who want to play for the
initiative right away and are much are
very dynamic and this is a great example
of a player who is a builder and one
thing that I'll say about Smith's LOF
and myself that's interesting is at a
certain point I came to really studies
me slope and there's a game the book he
published called endgame virtuoso which
really has
loads of his end games you know from
start to finish and this this game is in
there and I realized while reading that
that Smee sloth was a guy whose
principles I felt like I understood and
so I could more than any other world
champion after studying him I felt like
I could predict his moves and I feel
like I could understand the rationale
behind most of them now that doesn't say
that I was as good as him or anything
like that for example that before move
earlier I'm sure that wouldn't even
cross my mind but just that I have a
sense for his principles and that is
something I think is I can recommend
really to anybody and the idea that you
should find somebody whose game you
understand and try to get a sense of
what their chess principles are and
definitely here we're talking about
somebody who's a builder not an arsonist
okay
queen d8 and this was all part of his
plan when Brown did this right he played
Queen d7 he wants to move the rooks over
the Queen goes back maybe now Knight d7
and here we go night before so we're
just gonna look at the bishop and if
this funny staring contest we're first
of all we've opened up our Bishop on b2
and that's important but also it's gonna
be difficult for black to ever do things
like b5 and at some moment of course
Knight takes c6 could become unpleasant
the intention however is if the bishop
ever moves then we'll think about
playing Knight d5 okay
97 Bishop takes King takes
and let's pause for a second in this
position one thing I've noticed is that
there are many players out there who
never want to play against Amarok see
bind because it just feels so terrifying
and this is one of those positions a guy
who I think has been GM and residents
here Eugene peril Stein regularly gets
positions not as bad as this but he
plays a lot of positions that are
similar and let's just talk a little bit
about this position and the pawn
structure and what's going on first the
black King is a little bit weaker and if
anything he probably owes us a tempo and
that's gonna be big going forward second
this is a thing that all Sicilian dragon
positions have in common and that is
that in the Sicilian you get an extra
center point right so for example that's
our extra center point but the weird
thing about the Dragon is that it's
often simply not doing a big central
fight and this is going to be critical
for what goes on next because what I
want you guys to see is even though
we're dealing with two very strong GM's
both players miss at several points the
idea for black to play be six and it's
important it's going to be important in
a number of regards the biggest one is
we're just stopping Knight d5 now what's
the prejudice against C six
well you're worried about the d6 pawn
right so there's a part of there's some
reptilian part of the chess-playing
brain that's going to come up both first
me Slav M brown where neither of them
can even see the movie six because
they're terrified of this pawn being
weak and this is one of the fundamental
prejudices that I want to really get
into for thinking about how pawns aren't
people all right Black has several moves
here Bishop
a ch3 might be interesting but since
we're gonna get a similar position I'm
going to talk about the bishop h3 ID in
a second so rookie 3 Queen a5 check to
the king and black says I would love to
have this Queen exchange ok smyslov
is gonna say yes I think this Queen
exchange is a great idea and maybe you
shouldn't I mean he should because the
black King is a little bit more open but
this is his intention and let's look at
how he does it
Bishop h3 so actually have all moved so
far I think this is the only one of
Smith sauce so far they can call like a
clear mistake everything else you know
to move 22 here seems to be absolutely
perfect and it's all about this mistake
is all about pawn structure and Brown
doesn't see the problem with this move
so let's take a look what Brown could
have done here is taken and you can take
both ways with the rook or the the pawn
let's say we take this way and now play
a six and let's say a couple things
all of a sudden blacks position isn't
that bad this Bishop now owes white a
tempo because it's hitting absolutely
nothing now there's no more Knight d5
and the only thing black has to worry
about is the d6 point however you know
in this position if you place a f3 I'm
well in time to defend d6 let's say
Knight c5 and very supportive even
played King f8 first and then King e7 is
going to come
so this position I think is already
better for black it's a real interesting
turnaround because now the pieces are
free and the night on before isn't
looking so hot and in fact there's some
beautiful M games that Eugene peril
Stein has played in this maroc see where
you know he trades these guys off and
actually plays Knight versus Bishop and
one of the things that he proves
actually in these kinds of positions is
what's me Slough says in the book which
is if you get a position with blockading
nature the knight will be better than
the bishop and this is definitely a
position where the knight could
conceivably be better than the bishop
especially if it you know get some nice
blockade squares and we're going to see
that in a second so now this was it a
bad idea [ __ ] Beach 3 because the e6
move is so strong however it is in fact
a very rich yeah if there's some rich
ideas behind it let's look rug c7 F or
Queen to excuse me
F 497 and now 85
really putting the squeeze on and one
thing that I want us to notice is that
at any point white can play Bishop takes
d7 and play the night against the bishop
and this the you know this is one of the
things I know smyslov is now looking for
and he's looking to do it on his terms
so 95 I thought was probably the best
definitely feels like the most logical
and it will help us understand what
comes here if we understand night c5 so
the thing about 95 though is I think my
boy needs to now play 95 takes takes we
got a pin but this position is really
terrible for black I would say lost
because that poor a6 pawn is flailing in
the wind and it helps this variation
helps illustrate some of the ideas that
are lurking behind the a5 move then we
got any comments from the stratosphere
okay so the reason I wanted to go
through that variation is this move rook
cc3 look really weirds me and I also
kind of had to scratch my head to see
what it was all about
I wanted him both on this move in the
move before to take that was just my
intuition about what he should do and I
think I'm gonna call that a clear
advantage I think it's very unpleasant
for black but this move the funny thing
is if it were true that a six was not
possible then Brooks dc-3 wouldn't ruin
anything
but of course II six is possible and the
bummer for both players they didn't see
it it was I I mean you can there's a
habbo as possible and so many moves that
it's clear that neither one of them saw
the possibility of these six because of
the prejudice against the d6 bar but you
can see once the King comes here that
point is going to be amply defended and
it really wrecks both of whites minors
and that goes to the heart of what I'm
trying to say when I say pawns are
people the pawns are there to restrict
your opponent's pieces and make your
opponent your pieces better they're just
the tapestry of the position and so it's
very critical that we get over
conceptually the the notions that hold
us down with the pawn structure like
this where both simply thought it wasn't
uh wasn't a possibility now rooks ec3
besides missing e6 I think the intention
was a dirty trick where a knight c5 now
snip-snip takes and now we're actually
losing a full piece because b4 it's
always gonna happen and there's no
there's no way to get to your get
another rook over here because the
bishop let's say b6 and now let's look
the rook defends this guides that have
been being
see what so now we just take tonight so
it's it's interesting because in the
other variation right the Knight d5 was
pretty well crushing after Knight c5 but
he doesn't want to do it right so he's
setting up Brooksie c3 so it'll be
absolutely crushing if black plays
Knight c5 and that gives a good sense to
of what's where Smith's lavas coming
from in this endgame namely he really is
trying to squeeze Brown completely out
no e six should be played King EA a
strange move because he's setting
himself up for this kind of stuff
now Bishop g2 or excuse me Bishop takes
d7 is very strong Bishop g2 was played
in this position it might be a little
late now to play c6 because now there's
a kind of famous trick where we can do
things like 'if I've snip and then you
know there's a knight a6 problem so at
least now I don't think either of them
saw it because neither who were looking
at e6 but because Black has put his King
on a funny square there it's a little
bit more difficult for him to get away
with that so Brown plays King f8 no I
played Brown many times passed away a
couple years ago of a stroke and the guy
was really intense to play against and
was so much energy on the board so much
energy that he always got in time
pressure back then no increment and what
you can feel from several of Browns next
moves is that he was in Syria
time pressure moves like King II King f8
all right here we go King F to a
building move e5 now this is an
interesting point to talk about pawn
structure a metaphor that makes a lot of
sense to me is to say that you know in
life some of us are able to thrive in
certain situations and not in other
situations right so for example you know
the the slightly autistic computer kids
and the chess kids are now thriving in
America's internet economy but a hundred
years ago 200 years ago they wouldn't
have done so well it's not so easy and
the same way with pawn structures a good
role that I like actually is any time
someone changes the structure of the
position like II find us
that's the moment to change up how
you're thinking about the position and
so this next move Bishop h3 I think it's
technically a mistake but it's got a
very deep idea which is the following we
could have taken the night earlier we
had several opportunities to do so and
that would have been a great position at
least I thought so but now that ePHI has
been played what 'if i've declares is
that black is going to try to create a
blockade on the dark squares right and
also he is going to shut down the
advance of the e pawn so that this pawn
here is now just a duck let's call it a
walk he did duck
and so the deep idea of Bishop h3 is
that white is saying now is the time
that I would like to steal that night
and in a funny thing I'm sure Brown is
in time control time crusher but it's an
interesting thing here where I feel he
made his next move thinking to him to
himself well Smith sloth didn't take it
before now he's not going to take it
there really interesting so instead he
should move his don't allow the trait
for sure he's still a little bit worse
after moves like Knight f6 or Knight c5
but for sure it's incredibly dangerous
now to allow this exchange and that's
what happens okay Bishop takes is not
possible because of Knight d5 so rook
takes and it's a funny position at first
sight maybe it doesn't seem like black
is in that much trouble but he's in fact
let's say close to lost and it's yeah
it's it's hard to imagine what are the
factors well funnily enough even though
so much has been traded black still has
less space and one thing about less
space in end games is that your king
will oftentimes be either poor likely as
in less active or simply a victim and
definitely here the black King even
though he looks safe now he's under fire
and this rook is gonna come over here
and there's going to be it's gonna be
hard for him to find a square to land on
now one of the humorous things I want
you guys to see about this position is
we here two are going to have multiple
opportunities for white to play Knight
d5 but he's not going to do it it's not
gonna do it for a long time and that
it's again all these prejudices in
the position about like how you play
against black so here we go
rookie to f6 King III rook f8 and now
definitely a mistake here was I think a
really important moment where black
needed to excuse me white needed to
recognize the danger of black creating
counter play and I'm sure this was time
pressure for both players but still it's
really important to see that the crime
that Brown commits in the following 10
15 moves on repeated occasions is going
to be he thinks that this is a structure
of pawn structure where he can just sit
and be passive with his pieces and that
to me is the cardinal crime of in
gameplay maybe play in general but also
especially it's a crime that happens
when were either addicted to saving our
pawns or addicted to holding a certain
structure or addicted to not having any
weak pawns right that's when we say
that's when we do these kinds of weird
things and make our pieces passive
okay so rook d2 is a natural move but
one where the black can now get activity
with f5 and it just makes a lot of sense
he wants to open this guy up
he also open this guy up and you know
the best I could do here was Knight d5
but of course is that I obviously didn't
want to play this a nice endgame
actually is to think of it I think King
e6 is probably the best try here but
Bishop d5 snip and it seems at first
like maybe it's not so dangerous but
consider that this is a threat and then
these two pawns are going to be very
powerful Oh with the rooks behind him
and if a for before and then we put the
King on d4 and we really have one of
these building positions where at our
leisure we're gonna play c5 when we're
ready for it okay so let's go back rip
d2 and here's a really sad move I think
of all the moves that Brown plays in
this game this is the one I'm most upset
with and that's rook F da why because
it's so passive and ugly I'm sure I can
still I can still see the guy play him
so many times he'd be sitting there
making all kinds of noises and gestures
and stuff and freaking out and then you
play Burkett be it
okay so let's look at how it goes rook
d3 King e6 and now it's really
interesting thing happens here where my
guy my sensei is just unable to play
Knight d5 let's let's put it on the
board here for a second
so 95 and it's really annoying if you
don't take it because there's all kinds
of stuff like Knight b6 as well as
strengthening moves like b4 and you got
to watch out for
strikes like f5 so let's say you take
the thing takes King e7 takes well now
you can't take with a deep arm because
then if you take with a deep bond we're
gonna have to say that's lost and now
Baron like it's not necessarily lost
simply because the pawns are beautiful
it's lost because these poor rooks are
up against the wall of those pawns the
pawns are making the rooks poor that's
why it's so terrible so imagine
F takes rook f2 and I just said to
myself well blacks got to try that if he
wants to live snip-snip
King e4 he's got to try that if he wants
to live and rook f3 is a real Power Move
yeah very nice
pawn endgame because it's not that
complicated but it's kind of beautiful
we're we're just going to go back and
when we're ready we're gonna do that and
that's pretty well it cuz what we can
the guy can't move once we get ones once
we get there yeah really nice
so in this position my sensei does
something controversial and plays g4 and
right away Brown takes let's let's say
that that's correct and I think when
Brown played 'if I've something like
this was his original intuition which is
to things like a knight or player that
he was he wanted access the e5 square
eventually I like now though it
obviously it's kind of hard to get there
at the exact moment but also that the
ultimately the bishop wants to at least
dream of an open position and so we're
getting a little bit of openness now
Brown continues to play passively here
but I think here was his big chance g5
king III and rook h8 that's a great
example we we don't care about the pawn
weaknesses we want the activity once the
activity comes oh man I'm white better
watch out right I'm not saying white is
worse here but all of a sudden white has
to really start paying attention yeah so
and and g5 what it kind of feels like a
weakness doesn't feel like yeah yeah it
feels fine to me also ideally I want to
put my pawns on dark squares alright
rook c8 here they bounce around a little
bit clearly some time pressure and now
move 39 King III King D for rook f8 so
both players now get some time to think
about the situation and this position
let's say is incredible for white and
with the couple moves that black gave
white white was enabled to build his
position greatly here by improving the
situation of his King one reason I think
end games are so great to study and by
end games I don't really mean like the
de Varenne scheme manual where you're
learning about algorithms how to shut
something you know how to how to play a
certain configuration how to do some
specific mate but rather these kinds of
end games where mistakes on both sides
are going to be made but where you learn
to improve your pieces and think more
deeply about what a good piece and a bad
piece means and the reason I think it's
more interesting than in the middle game
is in the end game you've only got four
guys now notice I said only four forget
the pawns they're not people you've got
four guys right and if one of them is
bad that's a ratio of one and four of
your force that's now going to be weak
in the middle game a lot of times let's
say you got eight guys if you have that
one weak piece a lot of players even
2,200 players I don't feel it they don't
feel it as part of like their body
that's something that has gone wrong so
when you play end games or study them
like this game here you start getting a
sense of really thinking deeply about
how these pieces how their activity
looks and how they're working together
all right that's my that's my pitch for
the endgame rook f2 obviously black is
passive and he has to worry about g5 at
some point also very difficult for the
King to move now
one humorous thing about this position
is that it's getting difficult for black
to not move the bishop so black played
Bishop d7 and finally as if on cue
Smith slough is carrying through this
this plan that he started with I don't
know whenever he played e4 unmoved what
do we got here
move 13 right that's a plan he started a
move 13 which is we're going to stare at
the bishop until he gives me the d5
square and then he finally moves in it's
funny you know I did the commentary here
at the club for the Junior Championship
and Darwin Yang said this hilarious
thing about one of the senior games that
was going on senior championship was
going at the same time and he said it
looks like they're playing chess from
the 90s
yeah we just thought that was hilarious
and but he what he was saying you know
was it just funny but had a point which
is that back in the day before the
computers people played with plans and
you can see this as a plan in action
that is just kind of a guideline for how
he wanted the game to go and he's
definitely like it's happened now thanks
mostly to black being passive the thing
to say actually about the plan comment
the chest in the 90s comment that
applies to our theme today which is
pawns aren't people is that the plan is
only there to make your pieces better or
hear your opponent's pieces worse it's
not there to
do a pawn structure thing whatever
posture for example one thing that
ruined me was in that Soltis book he
talks actually about this Knight move
and he calls it the Marco hop I had
never even heard that term before since
the Marco and he talks at length about
this thing and it didn't help me because
I just one of my feet now I just want my
pieces to be good and instead I had all
kinds of visions of pawn structures and
what I'm supposed to do in those pawns
structures alright Bishop c6 are we
gonna trade it note we're gonna hide it
over there rook h8 and now this
interesting moment where after rook h8
now Knight d5 and what I want to really
give you a sense of is that smiie sloth
is a man who really I guess you could
say came to his senses and realized that
Knight d5 was in fact really a brutal
move to face and the first thing just to
see about it was when we take this way
now let's say the king asked to go to e7
we play rook e3 and how before and the
game's actually over because c5 is going
to come and we will land on some kind of
square like rookie six so he finally
sees it and this is like I don't know
what the fifth or sixth time he had an
opportunity to effectively land on d5
and he does finally do it
hf8 before and now honestly the game's
pretty easy Bishop d7 h4 white had other
moves as well h5 snip C takes now one of
the great things about 95 where there
was so many positions where we had both
II D and C D and sometimes there were
positions even with the rook takes that
were strong King d7 and here's a real
nice cold blood and move here h6 that's
really an old-school move
and that is the move that he had
intended with h4 h5 it's a great game
actually in the senior championship I
got in trouble because Ben Simon here
was talking at me and other people were
like Jesse you got to get off there's
other exciting games going on you got to
get your mo off of there he's talking
too long and I was like no we're gonna
talk about this and one of the great
things that your mo did similar press
and before he undertook any decisive
action stuck that H pawn deep in there
and it really made life a lot harder and
so let's see how this HP pawn finishes
it off here look over g5 rook over
simple chess now we'll bring the King in
and the point is there's no saving the H
pawn anymore because I always have rook
GA check right so rook d5 check and of
course King g8 I can play rook c7 King H
a trip takes b7 and here's a simple
truth about Rick n games that connected
passports they're absolutely evil so in
this position Brown saw h7 coming and he
resigned so one thing I want to stress
about a lot of these things I say here
you know is it's one thing to be a test
philosopher and have like notions like
pawns aren't people and something I just
want to stress from my own personal
experience of analyzing my games is
they're all the the pawn structure
things your presuppositions of how
you're supposed to play in certain pawn
structures they'll always be there and I
think you know you'll never totally get
rid of them but you can kind of work to
overcome them in the sense of just being
aware of them
right kind of maybe like our prejudices
in daily life right they're always going
to be there and then we just have to be
aware of when they're actually working
for us and when they're not alright
thank you so much and we'll leave it
there
[Music]
you